NICK PELLY: Hi, I'm Nick Pelly.
I'm a Software
Engineer and Technical
Lead working in Android
Auto and Google Maps.
GABRIEL PEAL: I'm
Gabriel Peal, and I'm
a Software Engineer on
the Android Auto team.
ANDY BRENNER: Hi, everyone.
I'm Andy Brenner.
I'm the Product Manager
of Android Auto.
And we're really happy
to have you here today
to talk a lot about
the technical details
and how you, as
developers, can start
to program your app
for Android Auto.
I've always been
completely passionate
about cars and gadgets.
And so much so about
a year and a half
ago, I ripped my
stereo out of my car
and I put a Nexus
7 tablet in it.
And this was before
I got to Google.
I put a video of
it on the internet
and it somehow wound
its way to Google.
And about two months later,
I found myself at Google
in Android as a
product manager working
on this super-secret
awesome product
that we came out with today.
Or yesterday.
So just want to go through
some of the challenges
we had when we looked
at the problem space.
Both cars and phones are
these essential devices
to everyone's lives.
So when we look at
phones, smartphones,
they really contain everything
about our lives today.
They contain our contacts.
They contain where we're going.
They contain our
next appointments.
They have our music.
They know our preferences.
And because they're
connected to the cloud,
these preferences follow
us around even if we're
on different devices or if we're
on the web using a computer.
So we love the connectedness
of these devices.
Similarly, cars are essential
for our daily lives.
They take us to our errands.
They take our families on trips.
We go on road trips
and new adventures
to find new places with them.
And most importantly, they
take us to work every day.
So many people spend a lot of
time each day in their car.
Latest study was
over 90 minutes a day
the average American
spends in their car.
Although they're
essential, they're
fundamentally disconnected right
now from our mobile phones.
So drivers want to have
those connected, compelling
experiences in their car that
they have with their phones
and so they take matters
into their own hands.
What do they do?
They bring their
phone into the car.
And they look down
at the phone when
they should be looking
at the road ahead of them
while they're driving.
And even though we all know it's
relatively unsafe to be doing
this, and we know in
many states in the US
and in many countries around
the world it's illegal,
people still continue
to do it because phones
and this connected experience
is so compelling and essential.
So those are some
of the problems
that so we saw that drivers had.
But we also saw that there were
problems that developers had in
trying to develop for the car.
And I want to talk a little bit
about some of those challenges
that developers have if you want
to actually develop for the car
today.
So first, there are many
auto platforms out there.
Usually, each manufacturer,
each brand, each model, and even
model years have different
software platforms.
They have different APIs.
They have different
capabilities,
which makes it literally moving
target for you as a developer.
Secondly, there's also
distribution difficulties.
So if you're a developer,
it's very difficult
to get your app distributed
to a car itself.
And once it is on the car,
it's actually very difficult
to make sure your app is updated
in the same way that you can
on a mobile phone today.
Moreover, there's
safety regulations.
And we're going to go into that
in a couple minutes about what
it actually means to
do some of this testing
you need to do in order to
make sure things are meeting
distraction guidelines,
which are around the world
and which many
manufacturers also
have their own guidelines of.
If you're a developer,
you actually
have to spend a lot
of time making sure
that you need all
these regulations.
And I bet you guys want
to be coding software
instead of learning about
the guidelines for driver
distraction.
And then finally, the
compelling experience
that people have on
their mobile phones
is that they're connected
and they're personalized.
And those are actually very
difficult to do in the car
right now.
You have a key you
put in the ignition,
and sometimes that key
knows like, oh, it's
driver one or driver two.
And it moves the seat
forward and backwards.
But that's kind of the
extent of personalization
that's in the car right now.
And so being able to have that
connected experience where
it knows everything about
you and it's able to help you
as you're driving is
actually very, very difficult
for apps to be able
to harness right now.
So what if it would be
as easy as a developer
to develop for the car as it
is to develop for an Android
smartphone today?
Well, that's actually the
solution that we worked on,
and that's Android Auto.
NICK PELLY: So what
is the solution?
Well, Google has
actually been working
in the automotive space
for quite a while now.
We first started partnering
with auto manufacturers in 2005.
And we've actually released
Send 2 Car in 2007,
Audi Earth in 2009,
and Places API in 2010.
These are all
cloud-connected solutions.
We're delivering geodata
direct from the cloud
to internet-connected cars.
These solutions are
already on the road today,
but we wanted more.
So from about 2010, we started
thinking very seriously
about how to solve the
problems that Andy mentioned.
And the solution wasn't
actually all that difficult.
We knew the key ingredient
was your smartphone.
This was the piece
that was missing.
Android is a proven
developer platform.
As you saw in Sundar's
keynote address yesterday,
there are 1 billion active
Android users at the moment.
It's a pretty insane number.
And I think most
developers would
agree this has been a
successful development platform.
Why does the smartphone work?
Well, your smartphone is yours.
It's got your apps,
your services.
It's personalized.
If you look at Google
Now on your smartphone,
it knows what your
destination is likely to be.
These are the kinds of solutions
that we want in your car.
We want your car to know you and
know where you want to go to.
Your phone also has a data plan.
It has connectivity.
So we want to bring the success
of the smartphone to your car.
The key here is we want to
bring success of the smartphone
to the car in a way that
gets around the life cycle
challenge of the car.
You keep your phone
for 2 years, but people
expect to keep their
car for around 10 years.
You don't want your apps to
not work on a 10-year-old car.
But as an application
developer, it
would be extremely challenging
to try and compile, maintain,
distribute your app to
every single car that
had been released
in the 10 years.
So if the smartphone's so clever
and the car's so challenging,
then why connect
to the car at all?
Well, it's because your car
has some awesome hardware.
It's got high-fidelity audio.
You've got surround sound
speakers throughout the cabin.
There's directional speakers
that can deliver notifications
straight to the driver.
You've got directional
array microphones
to pick up your voice
even amongst road noise.
You've got GPS and
high-quality GPS antennas.
You can't fit the
sort of GPS antenna
you have in a car in a
five-inch smarthphone.
[INAUDIBLE] wheel speed that
was measured directly off
of the actual rotation
of the drive shaft.
And compass, so you
can actually navigate
inside tunnels, which you can't
do as accurately on a phone.
On a phone, sure you
have an accelerometer,
but you have to integrate
the acceleration in order
to get speed.
And it's very noisy.
You're much better off taking
the wheel speed directly
from the car.
Cars these days have a six-inch
display in most new cars
coming out today.
And the display is
intelligently positioned
so that you can keep your eyes
on the road at the same time
as glancing at the display.
Cars are also
designed specifically
for being able to
interact with them.
Being able to use input.
Some of them have touch screens.
Some of them have controllers.
The controllers are placed
in just the right location
so that you can just quickly
toggle the rotary while still
looking at the road and
keeping a hand on the wheel.
Cars also have a
giant battery that
will make any smartphone
pretty jealous.
So wouldn't it be a
shame if we couldn't
bring all of this great hardware
from the car to your phone?
So we knew the solution was to
combine the best of your phone
with the best of your car.
What we didn't know is
what the right architecture
is to support this.
There's actually a
few different ways
you can combine the
phone and the car.
So we started prototyping.
And I'm going to
introduce to you
a little bit of our
development process here.
We started with an internal
prototype called Navstep.
On the left is a phone.
The phone that you have
in your pocket and you
bring into your car.
On the right is the
tablet that, in this case,
is emulating a head unit.
We're just prototyping here, so
we didn't have a real head unit
during these prototypes.
We just used a tablet
to pretend to be one.
In the Navstep
demo, we're running
Google Maps on the phone and
just sending navigation data
across to the car.
It was just turn-by-turn
instructions.
We were using Bluetooth.
I come from a
Bluetooth background,
so that was really
easy to bring up.
And we're actually taking
those turn-by-turn instructions
and then rendering
them on the tablet.
Pretty crudely in
this case, I've
just got a text dumped
onto the screen.
We were just developing
at this stage.
The key here is you have a
mix of the application stack.
You have Google Maps running on
the phone connected to Google
in the cloud sending low-level
data to the car that is then--
has some of the application
stack during the rendering
and the compositing
and everything else.
So this solved some
of the challenges
that Andy was talking
about because we could now
take advantage of Google
Services really easily.
Google Now destination
suggestions
can be sent from the phone
to the car very easily
with this type of architecture.
But we weren't solving
all of the challenges
because some of the
application stack
is still on the car, which
means that as an application
developer, you still
need to consider how
to get half of your
application to cars that
have been on the
road for many years.
The next step in our
prototyping was Navcast.
This is quite different.
We're now sending
compressed display and audio
data from the phone to the car.
Again, the car is the
tablet in this prototype.
So we're running
Google Maps again.
And you can see in the
top right of the tablet,
just faintly there, there's a
Google Maps image that we're
actually sending across that
was rendered by the phone.
Now, the key challenge
here is low latency.
It has to feel like
you're interacting
with a local system, even
though the application stack
rendering, compositing is
happening on the phone.
All those touch events are
getting sent from the tablet
to the phone.
And we have to do that round
trip as fast as possible
to make latency work.
So we worked very hard at this.
It wasn't easy.
We had to make changes to
the Android operating system
in order to do fast, off-screen
rendering-- fast rendering
to an off-screen buffer
that we could then
hardware compress
and put over USB.
We're using USB in this demo
because we needed the higher
throughput.
So we got to a point
through this prototyping
where I was convinced
that actually we
could produce a
workable solution here.
The latency, I really love it.
And I think if you go and
look at the sandbox cars
and watch our demos, this is a
very, very workable solution.
Now, the cast architecture,
it's a real turning point
because now we can move
all of the application
stack onto the phone so you
have that Android platform
that you're using.
You don't have to think
so much about trying
to get your application
code onto the car.
So [INAUDIBLE] able to scale
this and put dialer, music,
and more applications
onto the phone.
And we hope to have more of your
applications on the phone now,
too.
So this was the beginning,
really, of Android Auto
as we know it today.
If you're a podcast app, you
can now write for Android,
distribute in the same Android
APK that you're using today,
and see it appear on the phone.
And you can upgrade
via Google Play.
You don't have to
worry about how
to distribute your
application to cars that
have been on the
road for a while.
You can just distribute
them to the mobile device.
The last stage of
our development
was, of course, to partner
with car manufacturers
and to actually
get real head unit
integrations of Android Auto.
So that was the
high-level architecture.
Let's go into a
little bit more detail
about what this
means for developers.
Now as I mentioned, the
connection is via USB.
I actually come from
a wireless background.
I've worked many years
in Bluetooth and NFC,
but USB is the right
choice for our version
1 integrations because
you charge the phone
at the same time as you're
running Android Auto.
If you look at the
protocol, now the protocol
is transport agnostic.
It's designed
specifically [INAUDIBLE].
What we do is we map the
low-level hardware in the car
onto the protocol.
We enumerate all the
wide variety of hardware
that you have in the
car onto the protocol.
I'm just shown the
general categories here
of audio, display,
sensors, and input.
But within each of
these categories,
there's so many-- audio,
you have media audio.
You have cabin audio,
audio for the driver.
With sensors, you have
wheel speed, GPS, compass.
With input, you have all sorts
of different controller types.
The Android Auto
protocol knows about all
of this diverse hardware
and maps it directly
onto the protocol.
We also have display and
audio focus concepts.
So look, this is
really important
because we can support
use cases such as using
the native interface in the car
to select an FM radio station,
play FM radio.
You can then switch to Android
Auto, go to Google Maps,
pick a destination
suggested by Google Now.
All the while, you're
still hearing FM radio
in the background,
but you'll then
get turn-by-turn instructions
from Google Maps that
will come over the car speakers
and it will duck the FM radio
as the turn-by-turn
instructions come through.
Even better, of you then go
to a podcast app on the phone,
you'll then hear
the FM radio will
stop playing because
we're negotiating
audio focus over the protocol.
So if I go forwards now to
what's happening on the car.
You'll notice that there was
not any application state
on the protocol.
We're focusing on
hardware in the protocol,
so we have a small library in
the car called the Android Auto
Receiver Library.
It's a protocol stack.
It's a set of interfaces
to the hardware.
It allows automakers to
consistently integrate
car hardware with Android Auto.
[INAUDIBLE]
We have Honda, Hyundai,
GM, and Audi all here
today with integrations
of Android Auto.
And we're working with
many other manufacturers
in the background to [INAUDIBLE]
new cars on the road.
So looking at the phone, the
other end of the protocol stack
is in a component
called Car Service.
Car Service is distributed
in Google Play Services.
It also uses some of
the platform [INAUDIBLE]
we put into the L
developer preview
to support fast
off-screen rendering.
Now, for developers what
you're going to notice
is that we don't directly map
the hardware in the protocol
into APIs on the phone.
There's a really
good reason for this.
It's driver distraction.
It just doesn't make
sense to support some use
cases such as YouTube videos
or gaming on the car head unit.
Now, you guys are
all great developers.
And I'm sure you
think you can come up
with UI that is super-slick
and safe in the car.
But trust me, you don't
want to have to prove it.
We've got a User
Experience Research
team that works in
this topic, and they
deal with pages and pages--
thousands of regulations
from across the world that
define things like minimum font
size, contrast ratio,
maximum task completion time.
You don't want to become legal
experts in all this stuff.
You also don't
want to have to buy
a pair of occlusion glasses.
We've got a pair
here today as well
that Gabriel's going
to demonstrate.
As cool as they
look, you don't want
to have to buy one
of these every time
you release your app.
Now, what the
occlusion classes do
is they actually
block your vision
and then open it up for one
and a half second increments
to test that you
can operate the user
interface with quick glances.
So look, we deal with
the pixel pushing
and we deal with the
occlusion classes for you.
The diversity of
car hardware is also
challenging for developers,
especially with car input.
Some cars have touch screens.
Some have controllers.
When they're controllers,
sometimes it's a four-way.
Sometimes it's an eight-way.
Sometimes it's an eight-way
rotary controller.
Some cars have eight-way
rotary with a touch pad
on top that's separate from
the touchscreen in the car.
And some cars have
that same controller
repeated in the backseat,
where the backseat
controller sometimes
controls the primary display
and sometimes controls
the backseat display.
We handle all of this
in Car Service for you.
So what do we provide?
Well, we provide templates
and a common UX framework.
And we provide semantic APIs so
that you can work within the UX
framework that we've provided.
So really briefly,
here's an overview.
I'm going to actually
go to a live demo
with Gabriel to walk you through
the UX in a bit more detail.
So we're running on the tablet
at the moment, the same tablet
that I showed in prototyping.
It's an easy development tool.
It operates the same way that
your head unit would operate.
So at the top
right, you'll see we
have common visual
affordances that
are in predictable locations.
There will always be a
microphone at the top right.
If you press the microphone,
you bring up the Google panel
where you can have
voice interactions.
If we close this,
on the top left
you'll see that there's
an App Menu drawer.
This is always in the
top left and it opens up
the App Menu where we have
a list-based navigation.
Lists make sense in
the car because you
can operate them with touch.
They have large touch targets.
And you can easily operate
them with controllers.
Closing that.
So we also have Heads
Up notifications.
You heard about those yesterday
in the L developer preview.
Gabriel's going to trigger one.
There it is.
So Google Music
just changed songs
and showed a Heads
Up notification.
Applications can customize
content in the Heads
Up notifications.
There's also the Overview page.
This is your landing page when
you first connect Android Auto.
You can populate content
into the Overview page
as an application.
So we have a solution and
we have an architecture.
And we have a UX
framework that we
think is much safer
to use than trying
to use your phone in the car.
With that, I'd like
to take it to Gabriel
to tell you more about the APIs.
GABRIEL PEAL: Cool.
Thanks, Nick.
So now that you've seen
an overview of what
Android Auto looks
like and how it works,
I'm going to give you guys a
sneak peek of the Android Auto
SDK.
But actually, I can do
one better than that.
I'm going to give you
guys a sneak peak of how
you can extend
media and messaging
APIs to work not only
with Android Auto,
but also with Android Wear.
A big theme of Android
at Google I/O this year
is that we're expanding Android
to a lot of new platforms
and form factors.
It's coming to TVs and
watches in addition
to phones, tablets, and cars.
So while expanding Android to
all of these new platforms,
we gave ourselves
a real opportunity
to make developing for
Android a real nightmare.
This is a real thing
that we could have done,
but we worked together closely
with all the different teams
to unify these APIs.
So with both the media
and messaging APIs
I'm going to talk
about today, you'll
get native support for Android
Auto and Android Wear for free.
So the first thing I want
to talk about is media apps.
And media apps, we
found this to be
a particularly interesting
space for the car.
It's a crucial part of
the in-car experience
and we knew that we
had to get it right.
Users listen to lots of
different kinds of media
both on their phone
and in their car.
And we wanted to
make sure that they
had a seamless transition
between the two.
We think we found a balance
that both minimizes driver
distraction and enables
a wide variety of media
apps to feel right at
home in Android Auto.
At the same time,
media apps can still
maintain their brand identity
and bring the custom features
that makes their app
special into the car.
So what we've created
is a semantic media API.
By implementing that API, you
can future-proof your apps
and make sure that they
support all Android devices
across platforms as
soon as they come out.
One thing I want to note though,
is that in Google Play Music,
we're using the exact same
APIs that we're opening up
to the public, so that
your third-party media
applications are actually
first-party citizens on Android
Auto.
Let me just say
that one more time.
Third-party media apps
are first-party citizens
on Android Auto.
And we're using the exact
same APIs you guys will.
So let me just give you a demo
and see what it looks like,
and then we'll
dive into some code
and take a look at how you
can implement and wire up
your apps today.
So if I open up Media,
the first screen
that you're presented with
is the Media Playback screen.
And the Media Playback
screen, you'll
see familiar user interface
elements from other media apps
like album art, song
titles, subtitles.
That could be album art
or anything like that.
As well as some
familiar controls,
like, Play, Pause,
Forward, and Next.
I'll talk about how you
can choose and customize
those in your app later.
But we know that the
standard media controls
are enough to handle the
wide variety of media apps.
We want it to feel right
at home with Android Auto.
So you can even add
your own custom actions
with custom icons that bring
the special functionality
of your app insert Android Auto.
Right here, we're looking
at the Joyride app.
In Joyride, on
the primary screen
here, you can see that they've
replaced the Previous button
with one that skips
ahead by 30 seconds
because that makes more
sense for their app.
They have more actions than
can fit on the first screen.
And if we open the
overflow panel,
you'll see they have
some additional actions.
And there they have the
previous action as well.
If you want to switch
between different media apps,
tap the Media icon in
the Activity Bar again,
and you're presented with a
list of all of the media apps
that have implemented
this semantic API that I'm
going to talk about today.
If we switch to
Spotify, you'll see
that the UI is
familiar and consistent
across the different apps.
But at the same time, they can
customize their own branding.
So that the blue
branding in Joyride
has been replaced with
a green one in Spotify.
They also have
custom actions now.
So here they have actions
to shuffle and add things
to a play queue, as
well as start a radio
station and other
things like that.
If I open up the
app drawer, you can
see that again their
branding continues here.
And the scrim on the right
side of the app drawer
is green, so that no matter
where you are in the app,
the user will instantly look
over and they can just glance
and they'll know exactly
which media app they're in.
And they won't mistake
yours for anyone else's.
All the app menus live
here in the drawer.
It's fully customizable
by the app.
And you can see here, Spotify
has Your Music, Radio,
and Browse.
They've even chosen to include
a few custom icons so that you
can quickly glance over and look
and find exactly what you want.
If we go into the
Playlist menu, you'll
see that Menu items
even expand to fit
two lines of test if necessary.
So you really get a lot
of flexibility here.
So that's what media apps
look like on Android Auto.
Actually though, I can
only show you so much
on this Nexus 7 tablet today.
If you actually
use this in a car,
we integrate your
media apps into the car
beyond what I can show
you on this tablet.
In-dash and steering
wheel media controls
will control your media.
Your media metadata will
also be shown directly
on the instrument
cluster display.
And if the user temporarily
switches out of Android Auto
and into the native
head unit software,
your apps will still continue
to play and be controlled
by the same in-dash and
steering wheel controls.
So let's take a look
at the architecture
and what this thing looks
like under the hood.
I do want to note though,
that these APIs are still
being finalized, and
we're still making sure
that we get this right.
So some of the details of
the actual code snippets
might change a little bit
between now and release.
But we don't think the
high-level architecture will,
so you can start thinking about
how you can prepare and get you
media apps ready to
support Android Auto today.
The center of communication
in Android Auto
is in media service.
Note though that I'm
using the word "service."
When Android Auto is
running, we put your phone
in a special car dock mode.
When your phone is
in car dock mode,
we won't launch any new
activities on your phone.
What that means is that
all of the communication
between Android
and your app must
occur through
background services.
You can indicate which
service in your app
implements this
media service API
by adding the imediaservice.bind
category to your manifest.
As you saw in the demo,
when the user switches
between media apps
in Android Auto,
they're presented
with a list of all
of the apps that have
implemented this API.
We'll take the app label
from the application element
of your manifest, and
we'll also take the icon
by default from there as well.
But if you want to
show a custom car icon,
you can add metadata
to your service
with the name icon
and a resource
and we'll show
that icon instead.
The initial handshake
is pretty simple
once the user lunches
your app in Android Auto.
Android will bind
to your service
and you return
your implementation
of media service.
Soon after that, Android
will call load app theme
and you can have the opportunity
to get that customized branding
and look and feel so that the
user instantly recognizes it
as your app.
As you saw in Joyride with
their blue theme and Spotify
with their green, you'll
have the opportunity
to do the same and more as well.
There are four primary
things that you
can customize in the
theme in Android Auto.
You can set a custom
default background.
So if there's no active album
art, we'll show that instead.
You can also set a
primary action color.
Part of the material
design across all
these new Android platforms
is a primary action
that hovers above the
main card on the screen.
In our Media app,
that primary action
is the Play and Pause button.
And so the user can instantly
glance over and immediately
know how to touch and action
on the primary action.
If you set a primary
action color,
we'll tint the Play
and Pause button
with your app's primary
color so that it's
instantly recognizable.
You can also set
a panel color so
that when the user goes
to the Overflow menu
or opens the app drawer, we'll
tint that menu or the app
drawer scrim with
that color as well.
You can even set a custom
color for the progress bar,
so you really get a lot
of flexibility here.
Soon after requesting
your apps theme,
Android will request for a set
of default transport controls.
Transport controls are
the default media actions
that we found to be
common across a variety
of different kinds
of media apps.
It includes things like Play
and Pause, Next, and Previous.
You can set some default
transport controls
at the beginning when
your app is launched
and they'll persist across
different media items
as the track
changes and the user
moves around within your app.
You can change these
at a later point,
but if you want to set a
default set of controls,
this is how you do that.
We do know that this isn't
enough for a lot of the apps,
though.
As you saw in Joyride,
they add a special skip
ahead by 30 seconds action.
Every time the
media items changes,
we'll call get app
actions where you
can return a list
of custom actions
that are specific to your app.
And app action contains a
description string, an icon,
and a bundle.
We'll take the description
of the string and use that
to populate the
UI, and then we'll
send the bundle back to
you when it's actioned on.
That bundle is completely
transparent to Android.
You simply send it to us and
we'll send it right back to you
so you know exactly what the
user did when they tap on it.
When tracks change,
we'll call play entry
in your implementation
of media service.
We'll pass in the URI of the
new track, and it's up to you
guys to take action on it.
A lot of the time, these
actions and playing
a new piece of media in a media
app is done asynchronously.
It might take network requests
or various other things
that take time.
But we're not going to
make any assumptions
as to how your app works.
And it's up to you
to make sure that you
update the UI appropriately.
There are two parts to the
UI that you have to update,
the play state and
the metadata as you
can see in the slide behind me.
If you don't immediately
know what the next track is,
the UI won't change unless
you actually do something.
So if you're loading
something from the network,
for example, you can
actually change the metadata
to say loading and the play
state to say buffering.
But you want to act
on this immediately so
that the user has some sort
of feedback for the actions
that they take.
So that's an overview
of the high-level APIs
of how you control
the Media Playback
screen in Android Auto.
Let's talk about menus.
So as we saw in Android
Auto, all of the menus
live inside of an app drawer.
And they're completely
customizable by the app.
These menus consists
of two main data types,
they're media containers
and media items.
Media items are individual
entities that can be played.
It's actually the same
data type that you
use to update the metadata
when we call play entry.
Media containers are lists
that can contain other media
containers or media items.
And what you wind up with is a
virtual file system of sorts.
Media containers are
like directories.
Media items are like
individual files.
And it gives you
a lot of control
over how you want the user to be
able to browse through content
in the car.
Menus are a great
way to browse content
when the user can
afford to take the time
to look for what they want.
Sometimes the user
doesn't have that time
or it's dangerous
to do in a car.
So that's why we provided
an alternative that's
even faster and easier to
use than any menu hierarchy,
and that's voice.
Voice is integrated into
every aspect of Android Auto.
It's integrated
into the platform.
It's tied to your
Google account,
and it's tied to the
Google Knowledge Graph.
You can ask it almost anything.
You can ask it to
navigate somewhere,
call somebody, text a friend.
You can ask it questions that
are connected to the Knowledge
Graph, like what the weather
is going to be like tomorrow.
You can even ask it
to set reminders,
like remind me to buy
milk when I get home.
And it'll actually set a
geofence around your home
and remind you on
your phone, car,
and watch when you get there.
It's pretty amazing.
You can ask it to
play media, too.
If you say, play something
with Google Play Music,
it'll come right up.
But we want to
make sure that this
is enabled for third-party
media apps as well.
In fact, there's actually
been an Android action
in the platform for
quite some time.
It's called media
play from search.
If you implement this
action in activity today,
and the user makes a voice
search to play something
with your app, Google Voice
Search will launch your app
and send it an intent where
you can pull out the query
and start playing
that media item.
But like I said, we won't
launch any new activities
when Android Auto is running.
And so all this
communication has
to happen in
background services.
That's why we've integrated
this functionality directly
into media service.
When the user makes a
voice query in Android Auto
to play something
with your media app,
we'll call media play
from search inside
of your implementation
of media service
where you can then
respond to that query,
and then it's almost like
any other play entry.
That's an overview of
all of the Media APIs
that we'll be releasing
for Android Auto.
When we began showing this
to our pre-release partners,
they were able to get it
running in their existing
apps in a matter of days.
And it felt right at
home in Android Auto.
We're still working
with them to make sure
that we get you all the
best possible tools so
you can bring the best
experience that you
can to the car.
We do know that you
guys are working
on apps beyond what
we've imagined though,
so please come talk to us.
We want to hear what
you have to say.
Next up is messaging.
Messaging is one of the
most dangerous things
that people do in a car.
It leads to countless
accidents every year.
Part of the problem
is that drivers
have to take their
eyes off the road
in order to send a message.
That's why we've created a
100% voice-driven interface
so the user doesn't have to
take their eyes off the road
in order to send a message.
When a new message
comes in, we'll
display a Heads Up notification
and Google Voice Search
will read back the
message to you.
You can then reply to the
message with voice as well.
When we ship Android Auto,
we'll have full support
for SMS and Hangouts built-in.
But we know that people
use other messaging apps
and we want to make sure
they have the same seamless
experience with those
apps in Android Auto.
Once again, we've worked closely
with the Android Wear team
to make sure that you can build
your apps once and have them
just work across all of
these different platforms.
So by building support
for messaging apps
into Android Auto,
you'll also get support
for Android Wear for free.
At the core of this new
API is remote input.
Remote input is a
new class that's
part of the Android L developer
preview we released today.
It's also going to be in the
latest version of the Android
Support Library.
You attach the remote input
to a standard Android system
notification action.
In Android Auto when we detect
a messaging notification
with a remote input, we'll use
that to open up Google Voice
Search to let you reply
to a message with voice,
and then we'll send the results
of that back to your app
with a pending intent.
So there you have it.
What we're offering with the
first version of Android Auto
is a rich set of media
APIs that provides
a consistent UI for the
user, yet gives you guys
the flexibility to
maintain your apps branding
and keep your custom
features and make
them accessible in the car.
And a voice-driven messaging
API that minimizes driver
distraction and lets
drivers send message
without ever taking
their eyes off the road.
Because both these
APIs will give you
support for both Android
Auto and Android Wear,
there's never been a better
time to develop for Android
to allow your user experiences
to travel with the user
throughout their daily life
across different devices
and platforms.
We're really excited
to show you guys
what we've been working on.
We're going to have a lot
more information in the coming
months about the product
and about the SDK
and about opening up
this for all of you guys
to start working.
To say up to date, check out
developer.android.com/auto,
or leave some comments
on g.co/androidautodev,
our Google+ community.
We'll be monitoring
that and keeping
track of what people are
looking for in these APIs
because we're really dedicated
to make sure that you have
the tools that you need to make
a strong app for Android Auto.
So I think we just have
a few minutes left here.
We'll answer a few
questions you have now,
but we're doing live
demos in the third floor.
And the three of us and
the rest of the team
will be up there
all day if you want
to come ask anymore questions.
So thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDY BRENNER: No questions?
OK.
AUDIENCE: So my
question is, how's
the integration
with built-in stuff?
For instance, I
have a Leaf, which
has a lot of electrical--
all of that integration,
energy-consumption
type of stuff.
Does Android Auto
integrate with that
or do we bump out of
Android Auto to go to stock?
ANDY BRENNER: That's
actually interesting.
I actually have a
Leaf myself, so I'd
love to see more integration
with EV vehicles.
We've actually been working
with automakers and still
under discussions with
them as well as with you
guys on how to bring what we
call car data, which is things
in terms of an EV such as
range, battery life, things
of that nature, to the platform.
It's actually a
very complex issue
because you have
user privacy issues.
You have manufacturer questions.
We need to make a
platform so that it's
common across all the vehicles.
So those are questions
we're still working through
right now, but we
definitely want
to open that up to
you guys when we can.
But it's going to require
a lot of discussion that's
still ongoing.
NICK PELLY: We do integrate
GPS and wheel speed already.
ANDY BRENNER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I had a
question about the media APIs,
about audio.
Does this use a
specific media player,
or can it just forward
any audio using--
for example, [INAUDIBLE]
to the car audio?
GABRIEL PEAL: So right
now, just playing back
over the system media
stream would be sufficient.
And it will play through
the car audio system.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
I was curious, just
to be clear, is there
anything we can do right now?
Are we able to get
that experience
you had on the tablet on our own
tablet so we can play around?
Is there any APIs open
right now or anything?
GABRIEL PEAL: Yeah, that's
a really good question.
It's a combination.
So with the remote input
stuff, with Android
Wear because it's part of the
Android L platform release,
you can check that out.
You can look at the
Android Wear documentation
for more information on that.
But we're going to have a lot
more information in the coming
months about
getting an emulator.
You're not actually going
to need a car in order
to develop apps for the car.
We'll definitely be providing
some sort of emulator
or something, so you can
develop apps for the car right
on your computer.
But we're not actually
releasing any of the SDKs today.
But definitely stay
tuned, we'll have
a lot more
information coming up.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You guys
referenced briefly
that users would be
switching between the Google
Auto and their native
head unit software.
What's that transfer
going to be like from kind
of a user experience
perspective?
ANDY BRENNER:
Yeah, that actually
varies based on the
manufacturer's implementation.
It's up to manufacturer
to work on that transition
because, as Nick
mentioned, many cars
have very different
controls from each other.
In some it's a touch
control, in others
it's button presses
on the head unit.
So it depends on the automaker.
We have best practices that
we work on the automaker with,
but we want it to be as
seamless as possible.
And as Gabriel mentioned, if
you start media, for example,
in Android Auto
and then switch out
of Android Auto back
to the native system,
your audio will
continue to play.
We still have audio focus, it's
called, even though the video
might be on the native system.
AUDIENCE: So depending
on the manufacturer,
it could be either a touch
button to switch or a hard key?
ANDY BRENNER: That's right.
AUDIENCE: OK.
NICK PELLY: It may
also depend on what
you were doing on the phone
before you plugged in,
for example.
There's some context there.
If you were navigating on Google
Maps before you plugged in,
it would make more sense
to transfer straight
into Android Auto.
But if you had your
phone screen off, maybe
you just want to charge and
that's why you're plugging in.
So there's some context there
to help us decide as well.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: So about the
audio service type thing.
Obviously, most players
that want to play things
might not already have a service
that's running that does that.
And almost all of them use
the remote control client
to provide playback
controls on lock screen.
So why the decision to make
a totally separate service
instead of reusing some
of those components?
GABRIEL PEAL: So we
actually go far beyond what
you can do with the
remote control client
today in Android.
We want to bring as much
of the app experience
as we can in a safe
way to the car.
And it simply wasn't
a large enough API.
But we include things like
menus, and custom app actions,
and stuff like that that
you wouldn't get support
for if we just used
remote control client.
AUDIENCE: So the expectation is
that we have one service that
implements both the
remote control client
callbacks and these
callbacks as well?
GABRIEL PEAL:
However you architect
the app is up to
each individual app.
And it could depend, depending
on various implementation
details.
But the overall
architecture, it will
live in some sort of
service inside of your app.
AUDIENCE: Hi, you guys kind of
mentioned that the connectivity
through the USB docking, right?
So when the phone connects,
it transfer to the auto mode.
Will there be any
features in the phone
that get disabled at that time?
ANDY BRENNER: Yes.
So as you can see if you come
for a demo on the third floor,
we lock out the phone.
The phone screen is blank.
We put up a-- I don't
know if we can right now.
But you see a logo
on the screen,
we lock out the controls.
The system bar at the bottom
and the status bar at the top
are both locked out.
We want you to look
at the car screen.
And we think we have a
great experience for you
when you do that's more safe
than looking down at your phone
when you should be driving.
So yes, that's what we have.
AUDIENCE: And then, what happens
to the Bluetooth interface?
Today, all car
manufacturers support
the Bluetooth
connectivity, right?
ANDY BRENNER: Yeah.
So as part of plugging
in your phone to the car,
it varies on the
manufacturer but we generally
will auto pair with the
manufacturer's Bluetooth.
We use Bluetooth
for phone calls,
so that you can use your
car's Hangup and Answer
buttons on the
steering wheel as well.
So you'll actually have an
enhanced Bluetooth experience
with Android Auto compared
without Android Auto.
So Bluetooth is used.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So with the
fixed UI, how will it
impact the traditional
ways of the freemium
apps, which are ad-supported?
There's no place to
put on ad anymore.
ANDY BRENNER: So
we don't think you
should be looking at
an ad on the screen.
Kind of defeats the purpose
of what we're trying to do.
So we'd not really support
putting an ad on the screen
while you're driving.
But you can maybe
do an audio ad.
And we have some
partners, like Pandora,
that do have a freemium model
that we'll show you that.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have any information
on whether your
current partners are
going to charge for
the car feature?
ANDY BRENNER: That's up to
the individual partners.
You'd have to talk with them.
But they're using
their same APKs
that you would find in the Play
Store with the same packages,
and they're just enhancing
them with this additional API
set and service that
we're talking about.
So it's really up
to the developer
to decide how to
distribute their app
and what business
model they want to use.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is you guys mentioned a lot
about auto manufacturers
implementing this Android Auto
into their head units.
What about custom head units?
'm talking like big name--
Pioneer, things like that.
Would we possibly
see those sooner?
ANDY BRENNER: So we have
nothing to announce right now.
Some of the companies you
mentioned, like Pioneer,
have joined the OAA, but we
have no product announcements
on that today.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Any plans
for introducing
an SDK for
location-based services,
like navigation for example?
ANDY BRENNER: Yeah.
So that's something that
we're not announcing today.
We're focusing on media API and
messaging because we see those
as the first primary
actions that drivers
want to do while driving
that right now they
use third-party apps for a ton.
But we're looking at new
use cases for the future
and that's why we'd love to have
you join the Google+ community
that we had up on the screen.
Might be still up
on the screen there.
So if you go to that G+
community or scan the QR code,
we'd love to get your feedback
as a developer on what new use
cases we should support next.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
NICK PELLY: Or just come chat to
us, actually, the third floor.
We'd love to just hear
the exact use cases.
ANDY BRENNER: Totally.
NICK PELLY: It will help
us really figure out
what the right APIs
to open up next are.
AUDIENCE: OK.
My question to that
is basically focused
in on navigation application
outside North America
and Europe.
For example, in China
we don't have Google.
ANDY BRENNER: Yeah,
those are certainly
questions we're working through.
But we'd love as a
developer to hear
your feedback on
those type of things.
AUDIENCE: OK, good.
Thank you.
ANDY BRENNER: Please
come talk to us.
AUDIENCE: Hey, hello.
You guys mentioned car data,
like compass, GPS, speed.
Will that be available
to other applications
via like a broadcast receiver
or an antenna, or something?
NICK PELLY: Yeah.
So GPS actually, we integrate
with the fuse location provider
if you know about
that on Android.
So when we get GPS coming
in, that goes into the FLP
and is available to
all apps using the FLP.
AUDIENCE: Great.
ANDY BRENNER: One thing that's
important though to note.
With FLP and with any other car
data that we were to open up,
it would have to follow
the permissions model.
So we're going to
have new permissions
if we have other
types of car data.
For location, you obviously
have to have the location
permission.
That's very important
for users because we
want to make sure that
if a user's downloading
and installing your
app, they opt-in
to allowing you to
use their car data.
So that's a fundamental
part of Android
that we're not changing.
AUDIENCE: Great.
And one other thing to that.
If the phone is
plugged into the--
and you become in auto mode.
What happens to non-auto
applications that
maybe are running in
the background services?
Are they killed?
Are they allowed to let run?
NICK PELLY: It's still
running in the background,
but you can't launch activities
as Gabriel was saying.
But they could still
run background services.
AUDIENCE: Great,
thank you, guys.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So we're actually
actively working
on the Wear notifications.
And what I don't understand
is, if you've got that going,
will it translate
over to Auto, or do
you just have to do Auto
to then translate to Wear?
ANDY BRENNER: That's actually
an interesting question.
It's not only a
technical question,
it's also a user experience
and product question.
When you're walking around
with your Wear device,
we actually want you to get
pretty much any notification
that's appropriate for the user.
But with Wear, a
lot of notifications
are not filtered out.
But in Auto, we do think it's
very important that you only
get notifications that are
appropriate for the context
of driving.
So there's definitely going to
have to be a curation process.
AUDIENCE: It's a subset.
ANDY BRENNER: It's
a subset, exactly.
AUDIENCE: For sure.
But the thing I'm wondering--
ANDY BRENNER: From a
technical perspective?
AUDIENCE: If we're
developing right now for Wear
and this Auto stuff makes sense
for a couple of the things
we're already developing,
like how quickly can we
translate between the two?
Or can I combine that effort?
ANDY BRENNER: It
should be trivial.
With the latest version of the
Android Wear documentation,
there's a new extension
for notifications
where you can extend
them with Wear extenders.
We may have a similar
thing for car extenders.
So you can add additional
options to an existing
notification, but it would
be as simple as adding
a few lines of code
to some existing code
that you already have.
AUDIENCE: And then timing-wise.
So Wear stuff is available now.
We're hoping to have that
released, say in August.
And then Auto stuff would come--
ANDY BRENNER: Stay tuned.
NICK PELLY: Soon.
AUDIENCE: And we just flip
it with a few lines of code
is what you're saying?
GABRIEL PEAL: Pretty much.
ANDY BRENNER: Correct.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
ANDY BRENNER: I think
we're about out of time.
But if you have
additional questions,
please visit us on
the third floor.
We'd be more than happy to
talk with you individually.
Thanks a lot.